when we when we talk about modernity
what do we mean by that this is
something we've brought up before what
is it to be mine how do you think of
yourself as modern because you know you
don't think of yourself as not modern do
you what's modernity for you how are you
different than say your grandparents
yeah that's it was a huge one you grew
up with with technology like this right
your grandparents some of them actually
have to use you know the dumb down
phones that they make just for them the
Jitterbugs those of us in the middle Eli
had to adapt but also technology is
really important yeah so we have
opportunity for like higher education
yeah education gets more and more
widespread now your grandparents
generation had a GI Bill that you rely
on so many of them got to go to school
fairly cheaply which is different than
you guys since it's pretty expensive
nowadays but more of your generation is
going to college what else there any
other things that make you more modern
than your grandparents other than being
young in them being old really like most
religions are adapting to the new
society and definitely extension
what are you aware you know being taught
yeah a little bit different bands we're
talking okay that's a good point too
yeah so what you actually got is your
background assumptions you know the sort
of baseline stuff is very different for
you than it was for them you know for
example how many of you have credit
cards of one form or another very few of
you that's interesting because they
really market them up to college
students back in your grandparents
something they were your age very few of
them would have credit cards because you
paid four things up front most of the
time but credit cards are starting to
become a lot of process when I was your
age you couldn't use credit cards in a
lot of locations that is you know you
use them everywhere right a lot of
people don't carry any cash at all
that's that's a big change the attitude
towards taking on debt has changed now
imagine what about your grandparents and
their own grandparents how would they
differ how would your grandparents be
more modern than their grandparents yeah
having a car mobility that's a big one
what else yeah
people your your grandparents would have
experienced more or your
great-great-great-great grandparents
won't experience less okay yeah I think
that's right in part because people were
moving around as much what else yeah
design you're saying that that with your
grandparents there's less of a class
demanding the Rosary my
great-grandparents in the 19th century
yeah i think that i think you're right
there is more mixing and you know when
we talk about your great-great
grandparents generation we're actually
talking about the generations that were
around at the time that these movements
are really important and if you go back
further you can think about what else
counts as modern some of what we talked
about is as a liberal Protestantism fits
in with modernity those coming out of
seen an evolution as a major scientific
theory modern biblical criticism that
shook up a lot of people you know if you
were to go back say seven eight
generations and just walk around on the
street and ask do you think that God
really created the world in six days you
know some day he rested right most
people would have said yes oh I think
that would be the case down a lot of
people say I have no idea right but a
lot of people would say no that's it
that's an allegory you know doesn't fit
into module science this is a you know
this is the time when they were actually
fighting out these battles that the
thrust in large part are seeing is one
so there were a lot of other things
going on at the time as well that your
book talks with a large-scale
immigration many of your many of your
great-great-grandparents I'm willing
with that were in fact intimates matter
of fact you might have been your great
grand parents or your grandparents
that were the ones who emigrated
urbanization I mean it's concentrating
people in cities what a city's mean
besides you know bottom two ways well as
the city's just their kind of corrosive
they break down class barriers like you
were saying people getting exposed to
all sorts of new ideas see new ways of
doing things in industrialization all
these are major changes taking place for
the part of modernity and so like it
books us by the terms of 20th century
three broad-based new religious
movements these are all new these are
these are new things that are taking
place here in america emerged from this
cultural permit and they are going to
transform the character of American
Protestantism dramatically during the
following decades holiness
fundamentalism and Pentecostalism each
of them begins like it says is a climate
of opinion within a Protestant community
that was finding itself divided over
challenges that are coming about because
of evolutionary thought biblical
criticism and pressures towards
institutional what they call
routinization when things become routine
how does that feel you guys all have
routines right get up at a certain time
with what's your major concern with
right now as it as a student what
structures your your day making sure we
going yeah for sleep through my alarms I
mean do I go together but there you go
to get to class right classes are the
main things that structure your day
that's why he can't stay up as late as
you want even though it is college can't
go out on every single night because you
have to get to class because that's the
purpose of what's going on you do all of
you have a routine by this time in the
semester you know when you're going to
do homework when you're going to do
reading when you're going to go to the
library you can tell people basically
where you're going to be at what time
does that get boring you need to shake
up your routine once
was that one of the nice things about
being on break you weren't stuck doing
the same we're going to meet here now at
such and such a time talk about this
stuff well I mean the same thing is
happening in people's lives at this time
the same thing is happening with
religion and so holiness is a good one
to start with holiness is a movement
that starting from the teachings of john
leslie and who do you associate that guy
think back to earlier in class what
denomination was he important yeah very
good so this is starting out as a
movement originally with among the
Methodists and it comes to affect some
Baptists as well now think about what
Wesley was all about Wesley was about
religion of the heart wasn't he talking
about sanctification the need to
experience this connection to God
personal intense conversion experience
that would keep going on and on and on
that's what they called holiness or
sanctification now the methodist church
for a long time was known for that but
after a while things get kind of routine
and that kind of fell by the wayside the
more that they started to fit into
society and become just you know one
denomination among others so within the
Methodist churches there were some
people were saying hey we lost our our
focus wisely actually knew what the real
focus should be on holiness and we need
to do everything we can to try to get
that back so your book talks about this
Phoebe Palmer from New York who founds a
Tuesday meeting for the promotion of
holiness and the idea behind that was
having promoting this personal
experience of what was it called an
entire sanctification that's feeling you
you know connected with god and your
life have been fundamentally changed
palmer writes this book the way of
holiness and then there's a whole bunch
of other journals and books like it spun
off from that and this starts to develop
an institutional network they start
having camp meetings we talked about
those before camp meetings where revival
meetings you have a camp somewhere
people would preach constantly and
people get very excited about this over
the course of several days they start
holding summer camp meetings at places
that now kind of you know the elite go
like like Martha's Vineyard he and I
started building cottages and the whole
idea was to try to get away from the
ordinary routine and to focus intensely
on developing this experience of Holies
in a new environment your book also
talks about the higher life movement
this is a anglo-american movement so
it's involving people on both sides and
they follow the the reform rather than
Wesleyan theological tradition but it
but it also focused on this notion of
holiness or this notion of keeping
yourself apart from the world so if you
want it to remain you know the sort of
sanctified state one of the things you
think you'd have to do that mean any
changes in your lifestyle you're just
you know some businessmen at the time
dockworker somebody working on the
railroad the things you'd have to avoid
you can think of
a lot of these holiness churches
developed pretty elaborate codes you
know if a person really has this
experience they won't be out there
drinking for example or gambling or some
cases dancing why why do people worry
about the answer let me see that was
pretty innocuous I think these days you
know then go to a dance right have a
good time yeah cuz like they're
expressing themselves like like in a way
other than their guy oh that's an
interesting yeah you know if you really
wanted to like point out things in the
Bible you can talk about David dance
right he expressed himself that way
first his wife got really turned off and
seeing a dancing we also know people she
was disgusted with there so he must've
been doing some strange moves yeah I
suppose that could be part of it they
didn't put it so much in terms of like
you should only be expressing yourself
say his words more along the lines of
worrying about the physicality of
dancing what happens me for people there
you go you know and that at least some
of the things and that's probably going
to be leading you away from holiness so
that that would be a problem gambling
you know that would be another thing to
avoid that is there that would be
leading people so your book also then
talks about a few brain away churches
the Church of God Anderson Indiana
church of the nazarene wesleyan church
when we're talking about holiness church
as those are some of the denomination of
the associate that way your book also
talks about another one you may not have
to realize is a religious denomination
the Salvation Army Salvation Army is a
holiness denomination and they they're
called an army because they organize
themselves according to attend military
hierarchy and discipline
and they focus on holiness theology and
outreach to those who slipped through
society safety net so think about that
next Christmas when they're doing the
bell ringing let's move on to
fundamentalism when you do that term
fundamentalist what do you think of
right off the bat basics okay what else
yeah tradition okay traditions that
turned out actually a lot of their
traditions are are not very old there's
an old joke that good old you know
old-time religion really isn't that old
Thai dance it's fairly new this
developer named century well we use this
term fun of knowledge not just to talk
about Christians here's a much more
broad sweeping way what we mean when we
say somebody's a fundamentals what sort
of attitudes or behavior can you expect
them
would you want to fundamentalist
roommate why not I see some head shaking
that's something that's associated with
fundamentalism a very narrow perspective
you know obviously I taste like vaguely
they're related base often was like a
certain foundation how did you yeah I
think it's a good way to good way to
characters yeah as you're saying about
the same thing like they just follow
it's already know like it's already
written down okay so fur for Christian
fun thought was done what is what is the
fundamental what does the taste is going
to be remember these are processes or
not he's not careful and I Eastern
Orthodox so we're not we're not talking
about churches that are you know going
back to traditions in the sense of where
tradition with a capital T plays a role
what's what's going to be the basis for
that give you hit on me a book book
composed of books exactly yeah now
interestingly enough I brought in some
props when you hear talk about the
fundamentals with respect to the
fundamentalist movement this is the
fundamentals these this is actually they
released a number of different pamphlets
these are all those pamphlets that are
all sort of gathered together in a
2-volume set which I want fairly cheaply
because I wanted to see the
fundamentalist back then actually had to
say turns out a lot of them work we're
quite sophisticated well this is you
right they had a narrow basis on which
they would they would work from so i'll
pass these are out you can take a look
if you want to or or not fundamentalism
is rising in these Christian churches in
part because there's a lot of changes
going on a lot of accommodations to
modernity and some of these we're seeing
answer to breaking points places where
you can't compromise this any further so
you know for example the belief in the
literal truth of the Bible what they
call biblical inerrancy that's one of
the things that they took a stand up if
you subscribe to the theory of evolution
then you're not going to be able to bind
to biblical inerrancy in the notion that
every single thing said in the Bible is
literally true you can't have both of
those at the same time Kenya you have to
choose now is the open to you because I
mean that you can't have the Bible and
have the theory of evolution some way no
you could meet in the middle somewhere
and say well some of the things in the
Bible are just allegorical and that's
what a lot of the churches did
fundamentalist rejected that so along
with that sort of thing they also
rejected the notion that you know you
could explain Christ as just a nice guy
you know a really great ethical teacher
they insisted know either he's the son
of God or all bets are off so one thing
that you can say about fun none of us is
at least at this time they were very
clear about what it was that they they
believed in what it was that they said
well we can't compromise on this and
what happened in the churches I'm
talking about like president Peery and
Baptists Methodists is there were a lot
of battles between modernists and
fundamentals and the modernists
effectively want the battles within the
churches and the fundamentalists ended
up getting pushed out and forming their
own new churches so if there are
Presbyterians you know they might form
do Presbyterian Church a lot of Baptists
because the way the apt is tended to
associated you know could could be
fundamentalist and just disassociate
from whatever convention they were in
and so your book talks about their their
emphasis on doctrine they you know
that's what values there there are
certain things that doctrine or teaching
can't compromise they stress that you
know for example the inspired Word of
God is without error and its original
autographs that is as originally
dictated by God to the authors in
Scripture there were some other key
things that were considered before
panels the virgin birth satisfaction
theory of the atonement literal
characters of the miracles and then
there are some other things that are
added in there than it particularly
important remember we talked about
millennialism premillennialism is this
notion that the thousand-year reign is
nearby but a lot of things have to
happen on the way like Armageddon and
all sorts of trials and tribulations in
the coming of the Antichrist all those
sorts of things are coming out of these
apocalyptic flux and if you if you take
everything within the Bible is being
literally true well then you're
committed to that understanding of time
and understanding of what's going to
happen so one of the things that that
comes in that mixes things up if you mix
us things up a bit here is what's called
dispensationalism and this is a form of
premillennialism so to form that says
that you know the thousand-year reign is
going to happen pretty soon but all
these bad things are going to have to
happen first everybody's faith is going
to be tested and this guy Darby
formulates a notion of a whole bunch of
dispensation dispensation think of that
as like periods
and so you move from one dispensation to
the max yeah in each one there's there's
like a different structure different
plan for how things are going to be God
has different plans for two different
peoples and the Darby is late like your
book points out postulated to
supernatural occurrences they said that
the church age is nearing an end so the
church age is where where most of the
churches are actually like on the right
track how can you tell that the church
age is coming too and while most of the
churches aren't accepting this the
fundamentalist saw themselves as the
real traditionalist as the ones holding
on to traditional Christian doctrine
they were really doing something a bit
new without realizing it but they saw
all the other churches is having fallen
away from that's what the word apostasy
means and they believe that the rapture
was going to take place than the
tribulation that would be the Battle of
Armageddon and they also believe that a
lot of Jews were going to be converted
to Christianity and suffer for it so
this gave them sort of a man or a
timeline for what they thought was going
to be happy and one of the things you'll
find fundamentalist discourses doing is
trying to look at contemporary events
and figure out how do they fit into this
timeline how do they map onto it so you
know if you look at old literature from
the 70s or 80s you'll see a lot of
people postulating that you know the
anti-crisis arise in its a russia we're
back at that time the Soviet Union
Armageddon was going to be a battle
between who you know NATO which still
exists and the Warsaw Pact and then
after you know the Soviet Union Falls
and Warsaw Pact falls apart you know
they kind of revised who's going to fill
what role but a lot of this is coming
from his knees notion of
dispensationalism your book also talks
about Dwight Moody we met up with this
guy before talking about him in terms of
revivals Dwight Moody founds is moody
bible institute which is still in
chicago and is closely associated with
the fundamentals and that it finally
talks about the fundamentals which were
passing around better book roles in
another to this job as witnesses he and
Jawas witnesses are not fundamentalists
in the sense of you know being part of
that movement but they do have a lot of
things in common with them probably a
lot of you have encountered Jehovah's
Witnesses right as they knock on the
door and I'm sharing good news of you in
Long pamphlets yeah is ongoing joke
about how they're like so restful that
you can't close the door when you're
trying to like shoot in the way
yeah you know and that's there's a
reason for that stereotype because they
tend to be pretty aggressive and part of
the reason why is because they view
themselves as trying to get the word out
in a world that has turned against you
know God and turned against against
religion and they're trying to find the
lost sheep so you might be a wash sheep
and unless they work on you a bit they
won't find that out and it does tend to
turn a lot of people off you know I had
a fiancee once who they came to the door
and I wasn't there and then she she told
me yeah what if we come back at this
time because he'll be back then and I'm
sure he'd love to talk with you and I
hated getting into you know these
theological arguments but she she
thought because it was a philosophy
major huh they just not in any case your
book talks about them a little bit they
you know in American history they're
really important because a lot of the
landmark Supreme Court cases are
actually Jehovah's Witness cases where
because they would say for example
refused to salute the flag they would
encounter a lot of social opposition why
are they refuse to solutely why they
felt that that was idol worship in their
view there can't be any God you know or
you know thing to worship other than
Jehovah and any sort of acknowledging
you know things that we sort of take for
granted like say for the saying the
Pledge of Allegiance would really be a
form of worship for them and idolatrous
so so they they refuse to do that sort
of thing they don't serve in the
military that that was an issue to you
know conscientious objection yeah you
ever hear about that the most hated man
is America to Phelps family yeah now
they would sort of fill in to the
fundamentalist spectrum but is really
far fringe group within that spectrum
yeah their leader recently died I
thought it was done
no he's dead now yeah i provoked a lot
of controversy because where did they do
a lot of their their action on their
part is exactly as though so people were
like well what should we do at his
funeral yeah and it was interesting so a
lot of krishna showed up and they they
held up banners that said like what
we're not going to hate you sort of like
you know trying to stick it to him but
he fits into this fundamental aspect you
guys are all familiar with what we're
talking about this Westboro Baptist
Church they made a lot of media
headlines because they would protest at
soldiers funerals and they actually said
you know soldiers should die because
America had embraced the homosexual
agenda as they as they put it and so you
know we were an opposite nation that you
know we were a nation and falling away
from God and so therefore every
soldier's death was are like a sign of
how holler off work this did not go over
well with most people including the
families they saw themselves as sort of
like making a very deliberate point most
people saw them in a very different way
I think but yeah that's that's a great
contemporary example no sort of thing
back to Jehovah's Witnesses very briefly
your book talks about the watchtower and
some of their distinctive teachings they
are non Trinitarian they don't have the
same Trinitarian approach that most
Christians do they restricts full
sainthood to the to the 11 144,000 after
a while they had to sort of revise their
doctrine because they have more than
144,000 numbers and so they had a
theology of you know like the fully
saved and then the ones that were they
would get to spend time you know with
God Himself the other ones would be
saved but they would be honest
recreating the world and then everybody
else was going to the grave so that's
enough about those two groups
Pentecostals what are they what are what
are they fundamentally about when you
hear that term Pentecostal what do you
associate that does there anything that
comes to mind would make a church or a
christian pentecostal one there is
something distinctive plumb people will
say snake-handling but it's not the
snake handling that's a very you know
fringe practice among a few of them say
cuz Pentecost was like oh right the
apostles by now we're basically
missionaries after that because you can
speak different languages that's the key
right so directed book of Acts talks
about the Pentecost Pentecost is 50 days
after the Ascension and speaking in
tongues there's a technical term for
that will also lalia is always a
technical term for everything in there
usually it turns out to be some greek
words crammed together lhasa means tongs
lolly i mean speaking in babbling in so
speaking in tongues in the early 20th
century although there were
manifestations of this previously among
other religious communities there is a
movement that develops specifically
around the experience of speaking in
tongues understood as
gift of the Holy Spirit and the origins
of this are a little bit murky it looks
like it actually had three different
origin points a lot of Pentecostals will
talk about the Azusa Street revival
which took place in LA but that actually
has some background that your book talks
about with some other churches earlier
and pentecostalism starts springing up
in different places never provided one
completely unified movement so it's
split a couple times in two different
emphases and churches so if your book
starts out by by telling it a little bit
about the phenomenon we should probably
spend a little bit of a bit of time on
that early on the Pentecostals believed
that they were actually speaking in
actual human languages which they would
use for doing mission work and then they
went off to do mission work and they
found out that they weren't actually
able to speak the languages in the
places that they went to so the theology
gets revised and there's a lot of
different variants on some people call
the language of the angels some people
say it's you know spirit language
whatever it is what we do know
linguistically is that it shows
consistent verbal patterns those
linguists have studied this there are
dialects of it that vary from place to
place and church to church there's a
there's a lot of phonemes in it but they
tend not to be phonemes that the person
doesn't use and their their current
native language yeah it doesn't have any
sort of syntax like a like a normal
human language does is it a language or
not really that depends on your
perspective it is central for the for
these churches experience and for their
belief
so we don't actually have to decide for
ourselves how to view it it's enough to
know that for Pentecostals they do it is
as being part of abortion so your book
talks about Los Angeles Kansas and
central Tennessee is all focal points
and they don't want to say that the
story begins Topeka Kansas with this
Charles Fox parm he founds a Bible
Institute and according to to the
traditions people start speaking in
tongues and they saw this is sort of the
restoration of what was going on the
book of the acts after the city code the
real big explosion takes place in Los
Angeles and you don't you probably don't
associate Los Angeles with religion at
this time right what do you associated
with what is Los Angeles know before
Hollywood right what else the beach a
lot of California for that what else
record industry music industry what I go
to this is where a lot of new religions
popped up in the early 20th century yeah
Pentecostalism fits in there there is
this a zuzu street revival for three
years people are mixing together
remember at this time it's pretty
revolutionary have blacks whites
Hispanics and and others mixing together
eroding class divisions and all in
united by this phenomenon of speaking in
tongues so this leads to a number of
different denominations that your book
talks about the Church of God in Christ
which is largely african-american
denomination church of god Cleveland
Tennessee this arises from a white
holiness group Assemblies of God is one
of the larger pentecostal holiness
church and church of the foursquare
gospel these are all Pentecostal roofs
these are all Pentecostal churches and
later on what they're doing is going to
catch on and on some of the others
because we're going to see in later
chapters now your book sums these up by
saying in the early 20th century these
all experienced massive growth by mid
20th century they they entered into a
sort of period of eclipse they didn't
disappear they continue to gather
adherence especially what we call the
Bible Belt Bible Belt is the south and
parts of the Midwest and south west they
became sort of marginal religions
attracting both the poor in the middle
class or black and white in areas of the
country least affected by modernization
so when we're talking about the Bible
Belt we're looking at sort of a broad
swath that's that's more traditional
than other places the last thing a book
actually talks about here well those two
as things entice about here what is the
megachurch phenomenon the mega churches
what are we taking about this in mega
church there
gigantic churches where you can fit
thousands and thousands of people and
usually nowadays it's you know they have
big screens so you can actually see
what's going on those tend to be
associated with these groups early on
the other thing that your book talks
about that kind of put a cap in much of
this and relegated it to outside of the
mainstream was the Scopes trial what do
you remember from American history class
but the Scopes trial sometimes it's
called Monkey Trial why they don't
remember political cartoons you know
somebody holding up a sign Marilla holds
up a sign saying I'm your cousin it was
about evolution this guy's scopes was
teaching evolution in his classes and he
got in trouble for it he was in the
Bible Belt and he got fired and he
appealed it and the question was should
he actually you know be punished for
teaching what was at that time
scientific theory yes in a science class
and when it wound up happening was the
trial made a lot of these groups look
kind of kind of backwards and foolish
and led in part of their marginalization
so